[Music]
alright I'm here to spill soup I don't
want to cause no fuss but I just want to
say I'm the original ego there was no
one performing whether these Evo's it
was spam flyer and that's the first one
Botox anyway listen there's something to
be said I didn't my name is not of your
concern
no one needs to know are you sure that
my identity will be protected no one's
got to know who I am I'm very poor I
don't like what I'm gonna reveal some
teeth
well he's filling a lot of it everywhere
this is why this day all these other
bastards that think that they're part of
the ego train thanks forgotten about the
real to original ego whoever I am I
don't know why you don't know who I am
nobody in the world knows who I am been
able to keep my identity nice and secret
bullet things have been unfair all of
this charity March totally legitimate
charity works all available in
markiplier comms going to charity that's
why guys know what I have a problem well
I have a problem with this all these
upstart Evo's that's in today or the
riddles what I am I don't care about the
Google buyer it don't make any sense all
if that's a registered trademark what
it's all about yeah I enjoy it coke
everyone so
well that doesn't mean that I'm home
bike did that bore my face did that ruin
getting room nothing right okay I don't
want to be unfair but there's certain
allegations I um before Bing
they stole I've got a naughty list
oh I mean I've got a list of receipts
I've got receipts
I've got receipts on multiple people
about how some people have been back big
kicks dogs I know this I've seen it it's
on my list Google and Zell has killed
three people three and gold lining I
can't believe it dark that sweetheart
East child felt but each just a big old
[ __ ]
it can't be possibly invite her if
there's anybody is not on my naughty dog
not on my list of people that have been
bad he's going on not on it Wilfred
the dog the guy that I maybe know
louvered he is just like always kill the
everybody around me it's like burning
Lee's written it well I tattooed him on
my naughty list on my body
oh man left butt cheek I mean I've got
godless you can churn anyone it's not
fair that some egos have been treated
more or less fairly than others that's
all I'm saying
and if there were some situation where
egos could be treated fairly across the
board that'd be good for everybody
that's all I'm saying
[Music]
and if I could get a spot on mark black
why didn't I get waiting what oh there
was so much clearly missing from our
martini doll I would all want to help
anyway it's just like
[Music]
[Applause]
today charity merch like this
today
[Applause]
[Music]
hey everybody hey come on this week
charity shirt you get it today you you
happen you get it today you get a good
way
[Music]
[Applause]
so if you want to charity
[Music]
[Applause]
come with me down the streets of New
York where I'm from
Richard Voorhees no relation to Jason if
you know what I mean haha anyway come
see the Empire State Building
Hey
[Music]
we arrived greatest fears look if you
were good anywhere's and you've got
supported wrinkles like state of the
cancer are you mosey on down
Blanca you can find a great quality
notice filled to the brim with you that
nation anything you can be good me
things right here dreams of yours asking
wishes family desert action other than
the woman X well back in your life long
nice legacy look
[Applause]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Applause]
[Music]
and you know you get the best pizza in
the world
New York today yourself a slice of some
special come on
dyma mix it with some pretzels you go
home you got yourself a big pretzel
combo you know else you can get a good
combo this much good right so cool oh it
hurts I know
high-quality words when you know high
quality merchants we call stoic sorry
cherry we're gonna stand up against all
proceeds don't make a penny that'll make
enough money working in the shoveling
job that I got half bad pair is a huge
loss harder
[Music]
push mrs. Johnson push I can see the
head of baby boy anyway it may not be a
bouncing baby boy
dealing you know mark Blair calm why not
light up your life with these awesome
mustache lights all proceeds of which go
to charity
[Music]
[Applause]
cam and your camp going I've got bliss
the big middle to seek
I'll just stand here on the curb my
smartphone chambers he doesn't make any
money
what stupidity stand up the cancer let
me tell you what there's no stands on
one of me
I got back breaking leg on I'm here for
you you can't read nobody nothing like
that
I'm Ericsson here with derek derekson
charity board let me show you how these
lovely socks work and we love those
socks and we all know that the socks is
determinate on three factors fabric and
those are the three apps of socks
can't spell socks when it comes to fit
fabric and you kidding it better than
these shocks available of Myrtle are
calm and you can find yourself free feel
these socks
charity will kind of only mass let you
bug me products like this one here you
ever want to represent the true
signature
here
[Applause]
[Music]
look at all this savings you can get
Wi-Fi things for items you can buy
additional prize for charity and summits
priceless great stand up oh look at all
these feel to get mugged again what's
this you got pants got a notebook you
got dog fleas oh you can keep buckles
out there you mobile you are mr blog
comment see there's hell yeah
[Music]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Music]
take-take-take you know how to all
hey you person I'm not being
discriminatory I'm trying to tell you
about these great deals sweatshirt hey
what are you talking about anyway you're
going good day good day I'll never
bother you again
oh wow she's gonna tell you like Jerry
you like Jerry was all like carrots
[Music]
if there's one thing introduced when
you're a doctor it's a good hygiene you
always got to be certain about what
you're doing who you're doing it to and
so I always like to make sure the pie
hands are nice and clean
by buying awesome merch at Market
America you can go there get some
quality stuff and all raise money for
charity buy anything you want in the
entire store it all goes through a great
boss so just go there markiplier comm
pick out your favorite thing see you
there
[Music]
whoa okay you sexy person
hey listen I'm not mean no disrespect
here I'm just trying to tell you about
where you get coffee was the best place
on earth dicks coffee right here on 23rd
and 34 you get it every morning I get
everyone you stay away on the line
anyway no one's online market lark not
got yourself some charity merch stand up
Oh mine's like a jungle in here
you thought the item what called the
real jungle toward central bar you know
what senses where I am deal for charity
who's standing up to cancer boy you go
markiplier time you get yourself one too
please
[Music]
[Applause]